[Musik]
hallo zusammen und willkommen zu einem
genialen erdbeer-rezept ich liebe
Erdbeer Rezepte und ich habe schon
ungefähr 1000 Stück auf meinem Kanal und
jedes einzelne davon ist irgendwie
leckerer als das andere und heute gibt
es noch mal eine erdbeer-wickeltorte
hatte ich bis jetzt noch gar nicht auf
meinem Kanal muss ich echt sagen finde
ich komisch weil ich die sehr gerne
mache und die auch sehr sehr hübsch ist
und ähm ich starte wie immer direkt und
schreib euch die ganz genauen
Mengenangaben hier unten in die Video
Beschreibung einfach Untertitel
aufklappen dann könnt ihr euch dann
Screenshot machen und einkaufen gehen
ich mag das ja nicht wenn die Videos so
langarmig sind und kommt deshalb immer
direkt zur Sache ich habe jetzt hier die
Eier die waren bei mir im Kühlschrank
das war total kalt und besser ist es
wenn sie Zimmertemperatur haben daher
habe ich sie hier einfach in sehr warmes
Wasser gelegt für 5 Minuten und jetzt
sind die eben schön warm geworden das
hat natürlich jetzt keinen keinen
gekochtes Ei draus machen aber warmes
Wasser geht auf jeden Fall klar so
kriegen einfach ein schöner Volumen ich
schlage das ganze jetzt auf mit einer
Prise Salz mit Zucker und Vanilleextrakt
wir machen nämlich einen schönen Vanille
Biskuitboden und ich nehme dafür jetzt
die Küchenmaschine aber ihr wisst ja ihr
könnt auch euer Handrührgerät verwenden
ich muss ehrlich zugeben ich mache das
ja manchmal so dass ich mein
Handrührgerät nehme einfach um euch zu
zeigen es funktioniert auch aber mit der
Küchenmaschine funktioniert einfach ein
bisschen besser und es wird ein bisschen
fluffiger aber keine Sorge ist es geht
auch immer anders es gibt immer ein Plan
B so die Prise Salz hebt noch mal den
süßen Geschmack die unterstreicht ist
einfach noch ein bisschen damit ihr
richtig 100 warum macht sie eigentlich
immer Salz und süße Rezepte sondern
schlage ich das Ganze gleich für 3
Minuten und dann geht's weiter
[Musik]
schaut euch diese Masse an wenn das
nicht mal dick und fluffig ist da weiß
ich auch nicht weiter mit den Eiern von
unseren eigenen Hühnern weil meine
Eltern ich habe nicht oft die Eier von
den eigenen Hühnern da aber heute habe
ich und ich finde das sieht man auch
total an der Farbe achso nee das kann
ich eigentlich sogar ablassen damit ich
Platz habe für meine trockenen Zutaten
da habe ich jetzt einfach ein mehl und
Speisestärke ich gebe da diesmal kein
Backpulver mit rein denn das sieht
sowieso schon fluffiger Teig und ich
finde Backpulver muss da jetzt nicht
unbedingt noch mit rein so Speisestärke
macht das Ganze übrigens fluffig daher
bitte nicht darauf verzichten die Reste
hole ich mir gleich noch raus so dann
schön reinziehen entweder könnt ihr die
Maschine dann noch mal für wenige
Sekunden anschmeißen oder was ich gerne
mache ich nehme jetzt einfach diesen
schneebesenaufsatz mach so ein paar
Schwenker und sobald keine Mehl Nester
mehr vorhanden sind ist es fertig denn
das ganze jetzt nicht überschlagen also
nicht überbearbeiten weil sonst wird die
Masse nicht mehr so fluffig und das
wollen wir nicht ich habe jetzt den Ofen
auch schon vorgeheizt auf 200 Grad Ober
und Unterhitze und streiche ich das
gleich auf mein Blech schön flach
verteilen und dann für 12 Minuten backen
[Musik]
so jetzt machen wir eine cream cheese
Füllung die funktioniert auf Basis von
Doppelrahmfrischkäse dann nehme ich mal
ganz gerne Philadelphia weil der
schmeckt super salzarm einfach in die
Küchenmaschine auch hier könnt ihr euer
Handrührgerät verwenden wichtig ist dass
die Zutaten jetzt super kalt sind
Frischkäse ist kalt und auch die Sahne
die ich dazu gebe ich auch kalt da gebe
ich jetzt Puderzucker mit rein einfach
sieben und Vanilleextrakt das wird ja so
ein Vanille cream cheese ähm
sagen aber es ist eine Füllung
so und
wenn ich das ganze dann noch mal
verrühre und das ganze verbindet sich
erst auf langsamer Stufe gehe ich dann
mit der Geschwindigkeit immer höher und
gebe dann auch noch ein bisschen
Sahnefest dazu damit es schön fest wird
[Musik]
so die Creme ist fertig mein Boden ist
abgekühlt ich habe da einfach noch ein
sauberes Geschirrtuch oben drüber getan
damit jetzt nicht austrocknet und jetzt
machen wir folgendes wir brauchen
Erdbeermarmelade am besten ohne
Stückchen deswegen nehme ich jetzt auch
nicht meine chiarade weil die hat jetzt
Chia samenstückchen wobei das auch nicht
schlimm ist aber hier funktioniert
einfach besser wenn es so ein richtig
feine Marmelade ist und jetzt streichen
wir einfach die Oberfläche komplett voll
damit eigentlich nicht zu dick es reicht
schon wenn ihr so eine dünne Schicht
nimmt und dann geben wir darüber und
unsere cream cheese Creme da müsste
aufpassen dass ihr deswegen ist auch
besser die Marmelade nicht zu dick zu
verstreichen dass ihr die Marmelade
nicht mit der Creative Creme beiseite
schiebt aber das sieht so richtig schön
in die Poren ein sieht super aus
übrigens meine emailliertes Backblech
ist ja super super gerade ihr werdet es
merken wenn ihr das Backblech von einem
Ofen was mitgeliefert euch mal anschaut
da ist so eine Mulde drin und das ist
immer sehr negativ für solche Böden wenn
man gerade das Backblech habt dann backt
das komplett gleichmäßig gerade und hat
eben nicht diese Mulde wo sich mehr Teig
verfängt ich verlinke euch manchmal in
die Infobox und genau
[Musik]
so als nächstes wird unser Biskuitboden
durchgeschnitten damit wir sie
einwickeln können zu einer wickeltorte
jetzt habe ich hier gerade mal mit
meinem mit meiner Teigkarte ausgemessen
ich habe hier auf der langen Seite so
circa 37 cm ich mache die Torte 6 cm
hoch ich möchte sie nicht ganz so hoch
haben dafür geht sie halt eher in die
Breite denn wenn ihr breitere Stücke
ausschneidet könnt ihr nicht so oft
drumherum wickeln dann ist die Torte
zwar hoch aber sehr klein und ich wollte
deshalb gerne man ist nicht 37 aber ich
nehme einfach 36 links und rechts hat
man immer ein bisschen Verlust nämlich
jetzt die 36 geteilt durch 6 also
schneide ich alle sechs Zentimeter mein
Biskuitboden einmal durch und Roll ihn
dann auf
[Musik]
also ich finde das läuft wie am
Schnürchen es ist super einfach und
sieht sehr aufwendig aus und jetzt ganz
zum Schluss ich drehe es mal in eure
Richtung jetzt ganz zum Schluss noch
einfach diesen letzten Überschuss so ein
bisschen abschrecken ganz vorsichtig und
dann habt ihr laut meiner Berechnung
noch ein bisschen von der Creme übrig so
das Snack ich gleitet gönne ich mir
gleich so und ähm dann könnt ihr jetzt
außen noch ganz dünn mit der restlichen
Creme also das ist euer Überschuss das
ist wirklich so berechnet dass wir noch
ein bisschen was für außen habt oben
drüber bestreiche ich jetzt nicht mehr
weil ich finde die Optik einfach mega
schön genau und jetzt noch nach außen
verstreichen dann für 30 Minuten kühl
stellen ihr könntet sie auch sofort
verzehren aber ganz ehrlich wenn die
noch mal kühl gestellt wird dann zieht
alles noch mal schön ein und schmeckt
noch besser deswegen mache ich das
gleich und dekoriert das ganz zum
Schluss nur noch an der Oberfläche mit
frischen Erdbeeren
[Musik]
ich finde die wickeltorte wirklich
wunderschön und ihr kriegt damit so
würde mal schätzen 12 Personen satt so
und jetzt mache ich natürlich auch noch
mal den Test Test für euch das cool ist
ihr könnt euch jetzt wirklich so Schicht
für Schicht vor arbeiten
die fluffig dieser Biskuitboden ist es
muss auch wirklich so sein weil wir
haben ja schon viel Boden wir haben aber
auch verhältnismäßig viel Creme wir
haben Marmelade es ist alles
verhältnismäßig ganz super aber wenn der
Boden nicht so wichtig ist dann könnt
ihr das ganze Rezept vergessen daher gut
aufschlagen leute das ist ganz ganz
wichtig und ähm eben die trockenen
Zutaten ganz behutsam im unteren das
noch mal einfach als Nachdruck dass er
darauf achtet so
Hammer ich bin auf Wolke Sieben ich bin
so richtig lecker ich gönne mir das
jetzt noch mit so einem schönen heißen
Cappuccino wünsche euch ganz viel Spaß
beim nachmachen kann ich meine Erdbeer
Playlist machen ich habe so viele
erdbeerrezepte mache ich euch mal
verlinke ich euch dann unten in der
Infobox und schreibt immer netten
Kommentare würde mich freuen also bis
dann tschüss
[Musik]